hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a DA Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more
[Music]
how are you guys doing recently Tommy
the delinquent Robinson Tommy the chave
Robinson Tommy the low IQ Robinson the
uneducated Robinson Tommy the junky
Robinson Tommy the junkie Robinson the
one who's known for substance abuse the
one who literally went to Canada
recently and was everyone was saying
that he was you know going out using
prostitutes and using this and using
that and cocaine and snorting a few
lines of cocaine snorting those lines of
cocaine maybe he snorted a couple of
those lines before he made the video
that we're about to show you but let me
see what this uh lady who a witness to
this has to say about this very
interesting uh testimony we have here
and you know he's very ADHD and he's
very like he's very Twitchy and that's
when um you know somebody broke out the
cocaine and then
you know as a witness to trips to the
bathroom and then out came the Vodka
Cokes and next thing you know a dragon
had been Unleashed in this man and I was
like and that's when people are going uh
oh we have a problem here he went to he
went missing from the hotel people were
panicking so you can see with this
individual who's got very low levels of
self-restraint who's living the typical
hedonistic lifestyle who probably needs
Islam as a religion more than anybody
else because there's no restraint on
this this chave that this individual
here has come out recently backtracking
after I've issued him uh legal papers to
defend himself like a little boy the
little boy that he is to come to court
and defend himself for defamation of
character which as he will know is a
crime or is illegal at least in the
United Kingdom it is something not
allowed in the United K crimes are
something befitting to a man like this
and obviously common place to his resume
if you look at his resume of disaster of
course you're not going to find in his
CV any educational background you're not
going to find even GCS there you're not
going to even find uh maybe even SATs uh
SATs uh or anything like that what you
will find is a long record of him
assaulting people going to court
assaulting this person insulting that
person doing fraud mortgage fraud being
accused of misappropriating donor funds
and these kinds of things this
delinquent this this freeloader this
user this fool this
grifter has been using the
workingclass right-wing community of
Britain for a very long time to fill his
pockets to go to these countries to
snort his
cocaine and he presents himself as some
kind of Vanguard some kind
of um you know protector of the nation
some kind of activist
hero and we all know that he is
essentially a coward and what best to
exemplify this reality than the slap
that he received by the as salent in his
own Hometown let's take a look at that
slap and let's watch it together you
running away I know what you're like
brother you 100 you in a minute look
chees
you [__]
Chief prick now this is just one man who
slapped him one as salent one person who
assaulted him if this is the courageous
and gallant and Valiant man that he is
why don't you come out of his car and
defend himself like a man instead he
said a few words under his breath like
the little boy that he is the hesitant
little boy and he was on his way but
this is not the first and last time that
this coward has denied or rejected or
refused yes
engagement uh whether it be legally in a
physical capacity for example in a
boxing match with dill Hussein famously
he rejected this similar weight sizes
and so on weight categories he doesn't
he's not interested in fighting anybody
or in a debate capacity where with me I
asked him to do so and he didn't want to
debate with me he's not interested in
debating so now he's forced to be pulled
into the court of law and defend himself
like the little boy that he is and
present his evidences something that he
has not been able to do in an
intellectual capacity because of his
lack of educational training but this is
not just what we know of this man we
also know of him that here is somebody
who's for the longest of Times Gone to
court lost court cases because of the
amount of uh failures that he's that
he's perpetrated on a legal level uh
recently I don't know when it was I
think a few years ago he went to court
with a Syrian boy that he was defaming
and so on and Aji one of the lawyers uh
defeated him in the court of laws so
he's got losing record in debates he's
got a losing record in the streets and
fighting he's got a losing record uh
he's got a losing record in the court of
law this man is essentially a loser so I
I I just want to know that why are you
as a loser approaching me why are you
even speaking about me why you got your
why you got my name in your mouth and
why is it that recently you've come and
start backtracking like the little boy
that you are doing clarifications and so
on let's take a look at the recent video
Mo to set the record straight I didn't
call you a pedophile I said you advocate
for it because you say that in a in your
Great Society men would be able to marry
children so as you can see now he's
backtrack I didn't say this and I didn't
say that shut up shut up chav shut up
chav defend yourself in the court of law
chav and and fail again as you have your
gcsc and your Mar marriages and your all
of these things just like you failed all
that in your life just like you couldn't
respond to the man who slapped you just
like you couldn't respond to all those
people who bullied you in luten just
like you couldn't do this you think
you're going to respond to the champ you
me come on man come on man don't ever
don't ever try it yeah you're going to
have to go to the court of law yeah and
defend yourself as the farri delinquent
outcast that you are and
moreover I've got another thing in in in
store for you no it's not this
intimidation thing that you keep
mentioning playing the victim like a
coward because you are a coward oh he
knows where I live and this and that
I've not spread your house address I've
not said that not spread that I wouldn't
put your children in danger not
interested in that kind of thing we do
things honorably I wouldn't even fight
you because you're too small to be
honest too small in status and too small
in size I'm sure that's exactly what
your wife said you know too small in
status and too small in size um or she
keeps saying anyway and putting aside
this junkie Tommy Robinson who really is
a caricature for what is a wider
movement of farri Fanatics yeah and
these guys the far-right Fanatics
they're after our community the Muslim
Community in particular they've been
after other ethnic communities and
attacked them but now they're after our
community and recently we've got the
guardian reporting there's a
335 increase
3 35% increase of islamophobic attack
it's high time for us to respond and
that is why burning hands this
production this creative production is
one of those ways in which we the Muslim
Community intend to respond through a
creative medium which is most popular
among people and that people relate to
most that's why it's imperative it's
imperative for us to be able to tell our
story we can't just let these people
hijack the narratives hijack seats in
Parliament and case of Reform Nigel
farage who I was refuting a few weeks
ago is now in Parliament with his
islamophobic and
anti-muslim sentiments and so on and so
are we allowing this to happen without a
response and this is it shows you the
importance of the project like this so
I'm going to leave you with a a clip
with a character that reminds us of this
guy who now we're going to use for our
own purposes Tommy the junky
Robinson and you'll see the level of
produ hopefully with this clip God I
hope they move you somewhere a bit nicer
soon ain't that bead George we got some
lovely
neighbors well except except what got
this Neighbor Next Door all he's always
making noise and chanting his prayer in
there you ain't got one of them living
next door to you have
you one of
them you know babe those
limbs what's wrong with
Muslims a lot of M for
Muslims it ain't the people themselves
I'm sure if it weren't for that cult
religion there'll be decent hardworking
people you just can't see past the fact
that they affiliate with that religion
what do you know about their religion
arot hey you are you wasting your time
on social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a mid a DA Center
establishing a mid to convey The Message
of Islam is one of the best Deeds a
Muslim can do there's a huge need for it
in Norway you know this and I know this
so that makes the reward even greater so
give generously and Allah will give you
even more